today it's time to go up a dimension to
study shape and form in three dimensions
now the standard term for a three
dimensional figure is a solid example
here's a solid with flat triangular
faces and one square face in fact the
general name for a shape like this with
flat Ligon or faces is Polly he'd Rijn
coming from the Greek Hydra meaning to
seat and the prefix poly meaning many so
some sense this is a many seated figure
you can seat it down in many faces so
this is an example of a polyhedron and a
cube is another example of a polyhedron
example you'd call it a hexahedron if
you like so if you're playing a game of
Monopoly or some board game or something
else rather you could say please pass me
the hexahedron and you'll be technically
correct but people might think you're
little strange so here's some other
examples of polyhedra here's one on the
left with four triangular faces and you
might call that a tetrahedron if you
like this our pyramid on the right is a
five sided figure a Penta heejun and so
on now just to be clear not all solids
in 3-dimensional space are polyhedra
they don't have flat faces for example a
sphere is not a polyhedron nor is the
torus this doughnut shape way back from
lecture one not a polyhedron that
cylinder that Scylla excuse me that
circular cone there that's not a
polyhedron either alright but what have
you to do now is start to give some
names and jargon to these
three-dimensional shapes so in
particular I want to start with a very
fundamental shape with a very strange
definition people think I'm gonna be a
little bit weird at first because I'm
going to define a cylinder in a peculiar
way it goes as follows
a cylinder is a solid composed of two
congruent faces in parallel planes and
you then construct the rest of the solid
by connecting the boundary point of one
face at the top to its matching boundary
point at the bottom and if you take to
all these line statements you imagine
getting a picture
like on the monitor here that is called
a cylinder it's not what most people
think of a cylinder the flat faces at
the top and bottom which are called the
bases could actually be any shape you
like
so in some sense well in fact a very
real sense a rectangular box and a cube
fits the definition of being a cylinder
here at the top and bottom bases are
squares or rectangles depending on your
perspective here and the typical example
of a circular cylinder that most people
have in mind also fits my definition
I've got two circular bases top and
bottom and each point on the boundaries
of those circles a connected line
segments making that cylindrical
circular cylindrical shape now just to
carry on with the jargon we actually
have the basis the top and bottom parts
but the side surfaces affect any feature
that's on the side of a cylinder has the
adjective lateral attached to it lateral
meaning side so we talked about the side
face of this hexahedron want to sound
fancy also about this side edge which
case let's say lateral face lateral edge
and so on alright now sometimes you have
those lines coming down connecting the
bases at nice perpendicular angles to
each other and I call that a right
cylinder but you don't need to be right
all the time
my definition will allow for slanty
connections which case i would call that
an oblique cylinder so here is the
picture on the left of a bleak cylinder
with very strange shaped faces
nonetheless it's a cylinder and on the
right I have a hexagonal cylinder with
the side lines the lateral lines coming
down at 90 degrees to the bases so I've
called that a white cylinder but I might
even call that a right hexagonal
cylinder most people would call this a
prism and that's okay because a prism
means specifically a cylinder whose
basis happen to be polygons so many
people prefer to call a cylinder with a
polygonal base a prism
there is a right hexagonal prism all
right let's keep going because listen
because there is another basic construct
one can do in three dimensions which is
called a cone
and again you can imagine my definition
of coned is gonna be a little unusual
but actually correct and covers all the
cases we're currently thinking of so
what we'll do this time so having two
bases in parallel planes just draw one
shape and one plane and choose a point
directly above that plane somewhere
they'll be called the current point what
we'll do this time is connect that
current point to each and every boundary
point on whatever shape you drew down on
the flat plane below so you're making a
kind of circus tent construction now if
my base was a perfect circle like I've
drawn on the left here then you actually
get the cone as most people first to
think it is great that's a circular cone
or if my basis say a rectangle or a
square you get what people might call
actually a pyramid rather than a cone
but still fits my definition of being a
cone it's a cone and either the base in
some very strange shape we can have the
cone shape it's like a circus tent
construction the point at the top is
called the current point and like before
any feature on the side of this figure
has the word edge' tip attached to it so
to talk about a latter the adjective
lateral attached to excuse me so if you
have a lateral edge a side edge a
lateral face while the face is on the
side or if the surface is curved on the
side I'd call that a lateral surface
grant so we can actually go a little bit
further without jargon here if the
figure is perfectly symmetric in some
way the seams are intuitively right to
us then we might say that figure is
regular like we called regular polygons
the ones that had matching side links
all the way around and matching interior
angles all the way around so the
three-dimensional word regular would
mean for a solid something like the
following I would call that pyramid
that's their cone on the left regular if
the polygons at its base was a perfect
regular polygon in this case a square
and all side faces all the lateral faces
were actually congruent triangles so if
everything matches up in the way I
totally think it should
they'll call that a regular cone that
people reserved the word pyramid for a
cone whose polygon is a base so people
actually call that a regular pyram
pyramid is just a specific example of a
cone we also talked about regular prisms
if you like for the same same way that
each base is a regular polygon and each
the lateral faces are congruent so there
is a nice looks like a right regular
hexagonal prism or cylinder grand
alright so but our key question here is
not just naming things we can name
things forever in a day if we like but
let's really talk about the key issue
for solids would be their volume so we
begin else to study of area by defining
what we mean by the area of a
fundamental shape and we chose a
rectangle and we just declared it was a
declaration but the area of that
rectangle shall be its length times its
width we didn't try to define what we
meant by area but we just made that
beginning declaration and got a theory
of area going now we can do the same
thing here with volumes we could choose
a beginning shape and make a declaration
about what its volume should be now at
first thought you might say the
beginning shape we should go with is a
rectangular box and it seems reasonable
to excuse me to declare the volume at
that box to simply be its length times
its width times its height a times B
times C in this picture that's fine we
can do that but actually this
rectangular box is a specific example of
a cylinder so let's really actually make
the cylinder our fundamental shape in
developing a theory of what volume means
so let's declare the volume of a
cylinder
remember the bases can be crazy shapes
well declare its volume simply to be the
area of one of those bases times the
height so in this case the area is
capital a height is a small H the volume
of this particular object we shall now
say is the area that base a times H
alright so that means I can work out
some very specific volume formulas if I
so desire we example on the Left I have
a circular cylinder it's a base as a
circle let's say of radius R then I know
the area of its base PI R squared so the
volume of a circular cylinder will be PI
R squared times H its height and
actually going back to our rectangular
our definition of volume of a cylinder
matches the volume we had before because
the area of the base of that box is a
rectangle of dimensions AAB that area is
a times B so following my definition of
the volume of a cylinder it would be
area the base a B times the height c l
pops a times B times C just as we said
before this is all grand but there's a
potential problem with this example look
at these two cylinders I've made them
both circular cylinders that I've made
them have the same circular sized base
but one is oblique and one is a right to
cylinder and they have the same height
so according to my definition my volume
was just simply area base times height
so my formula says these two objects
should have the same volume do I believe
that would a right cylinder and oblique
cylinder have the same body does that
feel good to us this is a troublesome
question and it requires a little bit of
thinking in fact that question was first
thought about and answered in 1635 by
mathematician by the name of Bonaventure
Cavaliere and he actually thought of the
matters this way so there wasn't
photocopy paper in his day but he
imagined having a stack of papers like
this all right so there is a stack of
paper I was try to line up right to be a
nice rectangular box oh that's that's a
close approximation I say here's here's
a cylinder this really is a cylinder
it's a rectangular base and some height
so the volume is still on will be the
area of the base which is the ear one of
these pieces of paper times the height
the stack of that paper if 30 has a
well-defined volume right now I've made
it a right cylinder everything is lined
up at 90-degree angles
well that's close I can physically do it
right now so the question is if I make
this an oblique cylinder by pushing all
the paper sideways I feel like I could
have a little disaster any moment I seem
to be doing okay so imagine there's a
perfect straight line there has the
volume changed still the same area of
base still same height for the stack of
paper but now some an oblique stack of
paper well clearly the volume of paper
hasn't changed in this process
so if Cavaliere suggested well then
actually if an oblique stack of paper
has the same volume as before then the
volume is fact the same support in
general he argued an oblique cylinder as
long as the cross-section areas stayed
the same example each cross-section
areas the paper no matter what you do to
that cylinder make it a bleak keep it
right the volume doesn't change so he's
arguing that these two cylinders if you
think of them as stacks of paper do
indeed have the same volume so Cavalier
ease principle says no matter what you
do to a cylinder if you think of each
cross-section area as being a slice of
paper the volume of paper does not
change therefore the volume of all these
cylinders are the same Farrah's argument
even works for cones this debri was a
cylinder each cross-section was the same
shape it was a rectangle but if I
imagine having a current point example
maybe circular pieces of paper that
stack up into a cone even shifting those
papers around I feel like the volume of
paper in that pile does not change so
Cavalier ease principle says
oblique cylinders the Bleak cones have
the same volume as their matching
partners for us for the right versions
grant that means we're in pretty good
shape now the volume of the cylinder we
figured out is the area of the base
times the height it does not matter if
it's a bleak or right by the way what I
need to do now is work out the volume of
the cone so here's a current affairs
I've drawn two cones and clearly the
volume of these things is smaller than
the area of the base times their Heights
for example these fit inside their
matching cylinders so their volumes are
going to be smaller so I'd like to do
now is figure out how much smaller is
the volume of cone compared to its
matching cylinder what is the formula
formula scuse me for the volume of a
cone now what I'm going to do here is
push Cavalier ease principle a little
bit further so he talked about shifting
matching cross-sections of paper in two
piles of paper but if actually
formed the paper as well for example
here's a stack of paper with some weird
shaped pieces if I can imagine molding
each shape into inish in each piece I
like in fact I'm going to mold it into a
triangle if I keep the areas of the
pieces of paper the same at each level
that is here's two cones stack a paper
piece of paper at this level and a piece
of paper at that level if they have the
same area and I stacked with a whole
pile and all cross-sections at the same
area all the way up then I like to
believe the volume of these two stacks
are the same
that seems reasonable it feels
intuitively okay as long as I deform the
area of some form the shapes of the
piece of paper without change in the
area I'm not changing the volume so to
work out the volume of the current this
means I can deform the pieces of paper
these little cross-section slices into
any shape that's convenient to me and
right now the convenient shape is a
triangle so I'm going to work out the
volume of a triangular cone if I need to
have a different cone order is just to
form those layers those cross sections
into triangles the same formula will
work now what about to do next is gonna
be a bit wild it's gonna be a bit
confusing and scary at first we're gonna
take a deep breath because I this next
picture is gonna show us what the volume
of a cone is at least for triangle
occurrence here it is alright deep
breath as I said well I've got here on
the right is actually a cylinder is this
triangular SEMO triangular base size
coming up the triangular base at top and
if you look at carefully that cylinder
on the right actually does subdivide
into three pieces now try to draw a 3d
picture here and it's pretty hard to see
what's going on but there are three
chunks on that left each chunk there is
actually a cone a cone at zone right in
fact look at cone one the one on the top
in green is its face and its height is
actually going down with this kind of an
upside down cone this time current
number two on the left actually has
green base which I've labeled area a and
it's Hydra sort of going into the board
to the right and cone 3 has base B and
its height is actually going upwards in
a way I think about it
each of these really
cones moreover let's compare cones one
and three first because they each have
the same base space be at the top base
be here the height of this cone is the
side of the cylinder the height of this
cone is also the side of the cylinder
they have the same heights and in fact
in your mind's eye they've got the same
bases they've got the same heights and
you kind of see if you like to rethink
how this is the 3d parts and 3d thinking
is always tricky that each slice of
these cones are actually equal in area
all the way through so by cavaliers
principle two stacks of paper with all
the slices of paper at each level being
the same being the same area means
currents one and current three actually
of the same volume so volume of a piece
1 equals the volume of piece 3 now look
at currents 1 & 2 this time look at base
a because cone one also has a as its
base if I think of thats the base on the
side and height going into the board to
the right as well alright if you look at
the picture their bases are congruent
that the same shape triangle just
decides split in half to Congress trying
gel's they got the same base they have
the same height and in fact if you can
imagine all this cross-section slices
this way slices of people's piece of
paper they're kind of going up and down
in the board they're actually all
congresses so each slice of paper each
cross-section area is matching exactly
so by Carol Larry's principle current
one and current two have exactly the
same volume this is beautiful we just
showed volume 1 equals volume 3 and we
also showed volume 1 equals volume 2 all
three volumes on that left are actually
the same they piece together and make
the whole cylinder so each individual
volume must be one-third of the cylinder
three volumes in same heading to the
bottom of the cylinder each must be
one-third bottom of the cylinder so that
proves for triangular currents the
volume of a cone is 1/3 the volume of
the cylinder
it sits in and in general by Carol Lewis
principle they should work for all
currents so there we have it
we know that former
the volume of cylinder area base times
height therefore the volume of the cone
is 1/3 the area of the base times the
height that's a breath of satisfaction
that time all right
so let's actually practice this it's
time to do a practice example so let's
have a go at putting our old ideas to
work now okay our question for now a
regular square pyramid has space age of
10 centimeter say and lateral edge of 30
thirteen centimeters excuse me my
question is what is the height of this
pyramid what is the volume of this
pyramid
what is the lateral area of this pyramid
whatever that means and what is the
total surface area of this pyramid
whatever that means - all right so pi
this question is to figure out some of
the words in the question itself here
goes a regular square pyramid pyramid is
just a cone with a polygon for the base
so we've got a square base and a cone
point aa base edges right there must be
the late edge length of the base sides
and lateral edge of 13 are the lengths
of the lateral edges its regular means
all the symmetry I think should be going
on is going on in particular all the
lateral faces are congruent triangles
all right is that Y can prove a little
bit of work but it's tricky but you can
show but the symmetry of is so nice that
in a lateral pyramid sorry excuse me in
a regular pyramid the current point
horses directly above the center of the
polygon at the at the base that feels
right and they actually prove that's
true as well oh actually that's that's
what I need part of the questions to
work out the height of this thing so
actually do need the height like what is
the height of that central pole that's
holding up the circus tent there's part
of the question the other part the
question were the volume of this this
object and the lateral area and total
surface area must arrive to figure out
what they mean still all right so first
of all can I do anything to work out the
height of this object hmm well sometimes
it could be easier just to focus first
since I've got all the information
look at one side length side face of
this thing
one lateral face I've got all the
lengths of it so maybe I can least work
out the area of that side triangle
in fact it's isosceles I can probably
draw this line right here and note
because the symmetry and then probably
prove it with all the Congress and so
forth so a little exercise that these
two triangles are congruent
in particular this base edge of ten is
probably bisected ricci double check all
that so it's five centimeters and five
centimeters Oh which is nice because
that means it's going to be a bit of a
tight picture here that one half of it
is its own right triangle five
centimeters some unknown length 13
centimeters so I can use Pythagoras's
theorem to work out what's called
actually the slant height of the pyramid
so that's another piece of jargon the
height of one of the triangle face
triangular faces of pyramid is called
the slant height of the pyramid the
slant height if you like and it's handy
because that tells me how to work out
the area of the triangle its base times
its height its height it's the slant
type okay but what if I got I've got
slant height squared plus 5 squared
equals 13 squared well I said 169 and 25
they differ by 144 oh the slant height
is the square root of 144 that's 12 all
right
well actually I know the surface area of
one lateral face
I'm also do that right now one face has
area half the base half times 10 times
its height is 12 1/2 10 12 so the area
of one triangle is 1/2 times 10 times 12
what's that 60 centimeters squared so
that makes me think one part of the
question asked for the lateral area of
this figure now latch will always mean
side I want the side area but one side
has area 60 square centimeters the
lateral area must be all four sides
together so I said I can say that the
lateral area my intelligent guess what
that means will be the side surface area
of the shape would be 4 60s
240 centimeter squared okay that was one
part of the question well tell while I'm
at it public question also asks for the
total surface area total surface area
well I guess I've just worked out the
areas are for the faces the total
surface area must include everything
exposed to air well this is sitting on
the ground
I guess the base is not exposed to air
but it could be there held it up into
the air
I bet total surface area and I must
write ta for now would be all the area
I've got so far these four triangular
faces plus the area of the base base is
a square ten times ten area hundred so
this must be 240 samia's squared plus a
hundred centimeter squared 340
centimeter squared all right what's good
thing that no one expects me to answer
questions in the order that presented to
me because I think I've asked that the
last two parts of the question first
that's okay I was trying to get to the
height of this thing as my first go on
I'm not there yet can I do it hmm
well actually if I'm really sneaky and
clever I can see within the pyramid I've
got the height I'm interested in I can
go out to the line of 12 the base of the
slant height and that would make its own
right triangle within the pyramid and I
actually know the length of this base of
that right triangle again if everything
is regular everything should be
symmetrical the way I expected to be and
I could prove these results for want to
do a formal exercises and proof theory
that's all fine but I bet this length is
half the side length of the square there
must be five centimeters as well in
which case now is getting very messy
that's okay happens in geometry and
pictures get messy pretty quickly if
you're doing complicated calculations
but there is a right triangle and thick
green base five hypotenuse 12 and the
height H I'm trying to work out so
actually I can now say H squared
well my mark is not working very well h
squared plus 5 squared 25 is 12 squared
144 that tells me that h squared is a
what is that 129 I believe so
H must be the square root of 100 29
centimeters
oh that is a very awkward number
well yeah 144 take over 25 oh I'm off by
10 try 119 there we go it feels better
119 centimeters good thing I
double-checked my work there
all right the height is 119 centimeters
all those part of the question let me
Circle it I mean not even Mike let me
feel good about it
what's the final question they had here
find the volume of this square pyramid
all right the volume Oh the volume of a
cone or another pyramid is 1/3 of the
volume of the cylinder
it sits in one-third area the base times
the height I've got all the pieces the
volume is going to be 1/3 the area of
the base 10 times 10 100 times the
square root of 119 the height all right
not a very charming number but there it
is 100 thirds times the squirrel 119
centimeters cubed if I need that as a
decimal I could work it as a decimal I'm
gonna leave it like that
as grand and fine as it is all right
what's interesting here was that the
slant height was the key feature to work
out the side surface area and what's
interesting actually if this was more
like if I had a polygon at the base with
more sides to it this was just a
four-sided shape at the base four-sided
polygon what I had a hundred sided
polygon at the base I'll have a hundred
little triangles at the side and
exceeded the slant height would help me
work out the areas of each of those
hundred triangles but if I had a hundred
sided polygon at the base that figure
will look awfully like a circular cone
in fact if I had a thousand sided
regular polygon at the base that
probably looks so much like a circle
that I probably could not tell the
difference between it and an actual
circular cone so I see that these this
work could actually lead to formulas for
the surface areas of curved solids as
well I just need to go through those
formulas too and show you how they all
work so let's go back to the monitor so
here's a very basic curved solid the
circular cylinder
it's volume we know area the base times
the height PI R squared if the Rays the
bases are x height the lateral area
that's the area on the side of this
thing what is the area of that well let
me take a piece of paper again and I can
actually use it to make it cylinder I
can roll it up so that shows me the
lateral area of a cylinder is actually
this rectangle ha well what's the side
of the rectangle if I rolled up again
that's the height of the cylinder what's
the width of the rectangle and let me
show it to you this way the width of the
rectangle is actually the circumference
of the circle so this rectangle has
height sorry is there yes the side here
is the height of the cylinder and the
base here is the circumference of the
circle this would be 2 pi R scums of a
circle of radius R this would be the
height of the cylinder so that tells me
the lateral area of this object is 2 PI
R times H the area of a rectangle
formula and the total surface area would
be all the surface area I can see which
would be 2 pi RH the lateral plus the
area of the top pace basin scuse me PI R
squared plus the area of the bottom base
another PI R squared fabulous here's a
circular cone now as I said when I was
working with that pyramid on the
whiteboard if I made at a thousand sided
shape for a polygon at the base you'll
be so cone like circular cone like I
couldn't tell the difference and the
slide height is a key feature in walking
out this surface area so that actually
plays a role in obtaining the following
formulas well the volume of the cone we
know it's 1/3 times the area of its base
PI R squared times its height but the
lateral area really does depend on the
slant height obtained and here's the
slant height drawn on the circular cone
itself it really is the slanty height
and it turns out the area surface area
the lateral area of this cone is PI s is
totally derived with what we did with a
square pyramid generalized and the total
surface area will be the lateral area
plus any other area that I've missed
haven't looked at yet there will be the
lateral area PI R s
and also the area of the base pi
r-squared so this total surface area is
PI R squared plus PI RS let's keep going
now here's a pair of very very famous
formulas due to Archimedes around the
Year 230 BC he actually proved that the
formula for the volume of a sphere of
radius R is given by 4/3 PI R cubed
astounding and he also showed the
surface area of a sphere of radius R is
4 PI R squared
now one doesn't usually learn these
formulas until one takes a calculus
class and what's really interesting
Archimedes got these formulas 2,000
years before catalyst was invented he
found a very clever way to see that the
volume of a sphere had to be 4/3 PI R
cubed and once he had the form of the
bottom of the sphere he found a clever
trick for working out a surface area
from that and actually you can look at
this formulas they are actually within
our reach in my geometry book I actually
goes through all the details that
Archimedes came up with right there
fun to think about as you could think
about on your own so you can get to
these formulas kind of neat all right
there's my final little question I can't
help but notice something about the
formula for the volume of a cylinder and
the volume of a cone remember we said
the volume of a cylinder is area of its
base times height so here's a circular
cylinder volume would be PI R squared
times H for current 1/3 PI R squared
times H we're going to write the volume
of the cylinder as 1 1 of PI R squared H
compared to 1/3 PI R squared H shouldn't
there be some shape whose volume is
halfway between these two namely volume
is 1/2 PI R squared H that feels like it
should be actually there is and let me
show you how you get to it
to go from a cylinder to cone you can
think of the fact that we actually took
the top of that cylinder and pinched it
in in fact it's really a two-fold
pinching process first of all we can
pinch it in left and right and make a
straight line segment and then we can
pinch in the top back to forward like
take that top and squeeze it into a
current point
there is a shape halfway between those
two results beginning and end steps
namely just press the top of this
cylinder top and right sides in to make
a straight line segment and you get a
very strange cylinder thing well what to
call it actually there's no word force
but it has a straight line on the top
yet to be pinched forward and backward
it turns out the volume of this
intermediate shape is 1/2 PI R squared H
kind of lovely but these are the
standard formulas the formula the volume
of a cylinder the volume of a cone and
we're well equipped now to do lots of
great work in three-dimensional geometry
thanks very much